Ryan Ryan Fournier has the clip from Dan
bongino he says he makes a great point
on why it might be a good idea for Trump
not to post bail I'm going to play this
clip for you it's about two minutes long
hear it right from Dan's mouth folks I
don't think the Trump team should post
the bomb
I don't
but this may sound like a crazy idea
but folks we're living in crazy times
and crazy times require different crazy
bold approaches
Fanny Willis wants to be a smart ass
Tyrant little Socialist Communist like
she is down in Fulton County Georgia
don't post
don't post a bond
you jail them
let's elect our first political prisoner
go ahead
go to jail
let the Secret Service shut the entire
jail down and we'll see how long you're
willing to keep this charade going
let him put him in jail for a bit
folks I know it sounds crazy let the
Secret Service shut that entire floor
down because remember Title 18 USC 3056
and I believe 1752 the secret service
has the absolute Federal Authority the
supremacy clause they can declare
anything a federally protected area even
a prison cell they can clear out that
entire wing of the prison and make sure
Donald Trump never sees another human
being in that prison other than the
Secret Service I wouldn't post
you may think it's a crazy idea I don't
think so
folks you've seen people around the
world take a stand like this and it's
easy for me to say I get it I wouldn't
be the one in a prison cell but you want
to send a message
let's see let's see what happens we
should hold protests outside of that
prison cell every single day
don't post
don't post the bond make them put you in
jail
and make them show America their asses
and show America who they really are and
let's see how long this lasts
folks
I think the F around and find out the
time has long since passed
I agree he makes him build I completely
agree jail for him how crazy it is is it
that we're in this place now where we're
talking the prospect of a former
president who's also a leading candidate
I mean
this is really unhealthy it's really so
great it's so completely crazy and the
fact that the fact that there are people
that are my age like you know well into
their 40s that are accepting it blows my
mind because I feel like you could I can
understand why maybe younger people
would because they would be like they
maybe they didn't get like a really good
Civics education a lot of people don't
pay attention to the way that our
government structure most people think
the president has like you know
unlimited power and stuff but like
people that were born in the 70s or 80s
like you got Civics you should know that
the what that the pr how the president
has you know the authorities generally
the authorities that the president has
and that and you should know that it's a
terrible idea to prosecute your
political opponents your leading
political rival this is this really is
like Banana Republic stuff it's not just
um hyper like hyperbolic to say that and
this again
I know people like to give Tim Craft
about saying Civil War but when you're
when you're arresting your political
Rivals still been saying it for six
months now where's the off ramp because
where is it it's not I don't see it and
when one of the most prominent voices in
support of that polit of that political
figure says he should accept being
jailed to make a stand and become a
political prisoner political martyrdom
you know we are we are moving in Only
One Direction now I think he's right I
think a move like that Trump first of
all Trump will never do it Trump does
not want to spend any any time in a jail
cell he's going to get in and get out
but I think Dan bongino is correct if it
was anyone other than Trump perhaps they
might be willing to do it but I don't
see Trump being willing to do it but if
he does this he calls there Bluff he
forces these prosecutors into a very
very dangerous position of now you
actually have to Jail the front runner
for the Republican party do you want to
be the party that did that
I think they should
Jalen yeah
because for like for like his his
campaign if the charges this is why Dan
bongino is correct if the charges were
legitimate and they actually thought
that Donald Trump was trying to
overthrow the U.S government why would
they let him go
the what what what what is not
is it not like the highest crime in the
land to try and destroy the land
is is it not they're claiming he
conspired with a group of individuals to
overthrow the U.S government
and they're like
twenty thousand dollars you can leave
you're a billionaire it's all over it's
not it's not it's not even a difficult
bail for him to post bond it's like
they're two two hundred thousand dollars
and we just need ten percent of that
it's like okay do you want cash I got in
my pocket right now I'm a billionaire
they're not serious Trump should go
there and say no I'm not gonna pay you
know what I think they'll do I think
they'll say okay well then you don't
have to I think they'll let them go they
will not jail them I was saying before
that they should if their charges are
are correct I think they want him in
jail not now though
and I think the reason why they've been
avoiding is they know it'll help his
campaign
make him a political prisoner make him a
martyr martyr yeah political martyr
yeah what's crazy is Biden would
probably win
why if he was if he was in jail Biden
only one by 42 000 votes in three states
2020. I think Trump is deeply unpopular
among wide swaths of society Trump he
has a really really strong core of
support on the road do you think that
was true in 2020
I think that lots of people turned out
in 2020 with lots of people turned out
against in 2020. right so Trump lost by
42 000 votes in 2020. do you think Trump
will gain 42 000 votes or Biden could
lose 42 000 or any combination of the
two I guess any of those is possible I
just think that it is extremely late he
polarizes in a way that no other
politician does and so look my point is
that all of this is I I think largely
unnecessary right and it reveals a
needless insecurity on the part of the
democratic establishment that they're
going to these lanes because about 30 to
50 percent of the Republican Party
really really loves Trump another let's
say whatever 20 30 is strongly
supportive and then they have all the
others who don't support Trump
everyone else you know among
Independents and stuff it becomes much
more tenuous as support but it doesn't
matter
if we look at the numbers from 2016
Trump narrowly won it was I think 70
some odd thousand votes if we look at
2020 he narrowly lost but he gained what
13 million more votes
now Joe Biden got a bunch of votes I
believe through mostly anti-trump
sentiment about harvesting ballot
chasing the Democrats may bring back
coveted mandates and stuff like that I
don't know it seems every day we're
seeing more and more signs that they're
trying to bring back uh these mandates
but without that people aren't going to
be paying attention not only that if you
take a look at the polling even with all
the biases attributed that we've we've
seen so far
look I got I got a million and one
reasons to tell you why I think Trump is
on track to win not saying he will one
Joe Biden won because people hate Trump
and they did ballot harvesting there was
no Sports there was no movies you are
locked in your house you were angry and
Trump was the problem he was the reason
it was happening to you most but no idea
was going on
yeah then then you get uh no the
procedural stuff obviously but Trump
only lost my 42 000 votes despite all
that I don't think they're going to be
able to I think the Democrats are going
to lose a million votes this time around
which means if Trump maintains that
level of support he gained from 16 to 20
he would win by a couple hundred
thousand votes or even a million votes
this time around because the Democrats
don't have support they have anti-trump
considering how bad the economy's gotten
under Joe Biden considering
Afghanistan's whether or not that that
matters as much as the economy you saw
Biden's approval rating collapse with
the Afghanistan debacle
he's lost support throughout his first
term
I don't see why Trump would not be able
to make up these 42 000 votes this time
around it just seems inevitable yeah I
think so too
um I mean he just left those prisoners
of January 6th to rot in prison that's
not true and that doesn't matter to the
average person matters to me but it
doesn't matter to the average YouTuber
they might both lose votes Biden and
Trump are old man I I think Trump may
but I think Biden would lose
substantially more because they don't
have the lockdowns in the ballot
harvesting the same way they did before
they'll have to gear up the ballot
harvesting but there's a big difference
when everyone's forced in their home and
they can't leave you know you knock on
that door they're there and say that's
that right there it makes it all go away
just put Biden and you can go outside
and go okay now without lockdowns they
may have to lock things down you go
someone's house knock on the door no
answer no one's home you knock on
another door and say hey that anger
you're feeling will all go away if you
vote they're gonna be like what anger
the anger habit Biden the economy sucks
right oh yeah but Donald Trump abandoned
those j6ers the insurrectionists dude
I'm not voting for either them get in my
face
what I've seen of the what I described
as passively anti-trump folks from 2020
who voted for Biden
friends and friends and uh family and
family friends they are now passively
anti-democrat yeah that's what I'm gonna
say and I think it's probably because
like you might economic issues Trump's
not in office
there's it's it's not it's not easy to
point the blame at him we ain't doing
anything he's just sitting complaining
so they come and say you see Donald
Trump talking about stuff on the
internet and they're like I don't pay
attention that guy's not the president
they try to make the argument when he
was president he's the president he's
the most important guy you got to focus
on these things now it's like did you
hear about what that septuagenarian guy
in Florida said who
the former president why are you talking
about he's not Biden's the guy I'm mad
about I think that's going to cost Joe
Biden it's going to go back and forth I
do want to add though
uh as as a quick aside uh I it is it is
absolutely hilarious
that uh after everything Ian has said
today about Trump Hassan called
him a conservative
what did he say conservatives are
awesome or something the conservatives
are cool and and sunglasses he quoted
the video of you saying I won't wear the
mask and wrote conservatives are cool
because things are pretty cool man the
more you hang out with them somewhere
you like them thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time